[Musique]
jeune charles papa et maman
tout d'abord nous prenons quelques
instants afin de vous remercier de nous
avoir mis au monde au canada de nous
avoir transmis de belles valeurs de nous
avoir donné la fibre voyageuse et
surtout d'être tout simplement nos
parents on vous aime fort fort fort
saluer et embrasser la famille pour nous
noémie et audrey ces mots sont arrivés
une semaine après l'annoncé de leur
décès en juin 2012
c'est précieux
linda et karl bélanger doivent apprendre
à vivre malgré l'immense chagrin d'avoir
perdu deux enfants en même temps
sur garde la mangue qui arrivent à
l'aéroport quitté voir partir ce jeudi
pour coincer les deux bien qu'ils sont
parvenus
pourquoi que c'était dingue sont au menu
il ya des milliards du prêt de la bien
que tu dis là dessus van loc
il ya des morts mais tu dis pourquoi les
nôtres fois passé du pourcentage qui
sont parvenus 1
les deux soeurs bélanger ont quitté
faune également qu'en mai 2012 pour
voyager un mois en asie
le 12 juin elle était en thaïlande sur
les de pipi comme tous les jeunes sur
l'île audrey et noémie ont fêté avec
deux amis brésiliens
vers une heure du matin elles sont
rentrés à l'hôtel c'était leur première
nuit sur cette île paradisiaque et ce
sera leur dernière on les retrouvera
morte deux jours plus tard dans leur
chambre
que s'est-il passé cette nuit là un an
et demi plus tard les parents attendent
toujours des explications entre la
tristesse et la colère
ils attendent des réponses de l' enquête
du coroner du québec faire un deuil
c'est difficile de faire un deuil de
cartons de ces pots de quoi c'est encore
plus dur parce que moi c'est total
l'interrogation c'est tout le temps ça
ne trouve tout le temps dans time qu'est
ce qui a pu se passer y ont souffert
aucune nouvelle rien pour expliquer
comment leurs deux enfants ont pu se
coucher un soin et ne jamais se
réveiller le mystère s'éclaircit
noémie et audrey ont fort probablement
été intoxiqué par un pesticide
investissent est très toxique qui tue
tout ce qui respire
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
trois ans avant le décès des deux soeurs
bélanger deux autres jeunes femmes sont
mortes dans un hôtel de pipi dans des
circonstances similaires
wilders a vu mourir sa fiancée jo
saintonge sans pouvoir intervenir après
cinq jours sur l'île gilles et wyon
cherche une chambre avec l'air climatisé
il s'installe au la lina guest house
vers 11 heures du matin
jill qui n'a pas bien dormi les derniers
jours à cause de la chaleur
sandor rapidement pendant ce temps
varion s'installe dans un café internet
pour donner des nouvelles à sa famille
quatre heures plus tard jay est réveillé
et le couple sort manger
nous sommes sortis nous promener 10 a
dit qu'elle se sentait pas pour manger
une pizza sur la plage ou même
restaurant une berge étions déjà après
avoir mangé jill se plaignait beaucoup
les son état empirait
elle avait mal à l'estomac il a décidé
de retourner à la chambre se reposait
bayonne reste à la plage avec des amis
de trois heures plus tard il rejoint
tient à l'hôtel
quand je suis revenu à la chambre gilles
était vraiment malade au rseq
chaque accès elle se plaignait de
grandes douleurs à l'estomac elle
vomissait beaucoup se sentait étourdie
je ne savais pas quoi faire
nous sommes étendus survie puis elle a
commencé à dire j'ai du mal à respirer
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas faire que
j'étais dans la chambre quand j'ai
commencé à me sentir mal à me souviens
d'avoir pris la poubelle pour vomir
de son côté gilles était recroquevillée
devant lui crispé je me rappelle des
derniers mots qu'elle a prononcées
je n'arrive plus à respirer je n'arrive
plus à respirer et eu tellement peur je
ne savais pas quoi faire
je suis sortie en courant j'ai trouvé un
chariot à bagages je lui ai apporté à la
chambre la gym touchaient des
gémissements et enveloppé dans une
couverture
les mystérieux là que j'ai remarqué que
sa peau avait changé de couleur elle
était bleu ses lèvres était devenu bleu
le bout de ses doigts étaient bleus ils
courent jusqu'à la clinique
immédiatement un infirmier administra
jill la réanimation cardiorespiratoire
mais le personnel infirmier malice ou
une bonbonne d'oxygène dans une autre
salle après quelques minutes je me suis
senti un peu mieux je suis levé je me
suis dirigé vers la salle je trouvais
jill star le médecin m'a tout de suite
arrêté et il m'a dit elle est morte
c'est pas possible je ne savais pas quoi
faire elle a noté je me suis effondré
sur le sol et j'ai crié je ne pouvais
pas le croire
ses deux filles étaient heureux et en
santé est aujourd'hui crowe fait elle
est morte d'un cheptel
comble d'horreur le lendemain de la mort
de jean saint-onge dans le même hôtel
julie boy rames tombent malades ou même
moment sa mère dina thompson a un
mauvais pressentiment et les venus à
toronto nous raconter la mort de sa
fille
toi seul son deuil c'était un dimanche
j'étais à vélo à drammen ballet new bike
j'ai soudainement eu le sentiment que
julie avait besoin de moi
yolaine et des to talk to me donne à
fond de jeu les téléphonies je ne
souviens plus où j'étais exactement inde
[Musique]
chez cède elle m'a dit je ne me sens
vraiment pas bien maman je suis malade
imbert sec
[Musique]
elle m'a dit mon ami karina aussi est
malade à cette dame que je lui dis de
voir un médecin
à quand elle m'a dit je ne peux plus je
n'en ai plus la force
aucun anthony moi c'est la femme de
chambre qui sonnera l'alarmé
karina s'en sort mais pour julie il sera
trop tard
elle meurt en arrivant à l'hôpital
une première autopsie est fait en
thaïlande
mais elle n'explique rien et cette stop
breathing il conclut qu elle a manqué
d'air c'est tout a dit son coeur s'est
arrêté de battre
elle ne respirait plus et il ne savait
pas pourquoi vd donc norway
les symptômes sont exactement les mêmes
que ceux de jesse saintonge et des deux
soeurs bélanger difficultés à respirer
et les extrémités bleus mais l'autre le
saison gld mains et de pieds sont
devenus bleus mais son commerce
elle se sentait étourdie des sauces
[Applaudissements]
deux jeunes femmes sont donc mortes en
même temps dans deux chambres voisines
l'a4 et l'a5
dans ces deux cas la police thaïlandaise
a écarté très vite toute piste
criminelle
puisqu'il n'y avait aucune marque de
violence mais elle n'a jamais trouvé la
cause
[Musique]
trois ans plus tard dans le cas d'audrey
et noémie bélanger les autorités
thaïlandaises ont avancé toutes sortes
de théories de l'intoxication
alimentaire aux champignons magiques
sam t il
chebbi est semée biais passé mais
intoxiqué mais par quoi
par qui le pathologiste qui a fait
l'autopsié à bangkok a trouvé dans leur
sens un insecticide le dit qu il a cru
qu'elle avait été intoxiqué par un
cocktail
cette théorie avaient été réfutées par
les experts canadiens avec les dosages
où les concentrations de dès qu'on ne
retrouvait dans les deux jeunes femmes
ça ne correspond pas à des
concentrations toxiques encore moins une
concentration qui pourraient être
mortels professeur et journaliste
scientifique deborah blum questionne les
motivations derrière ces fausses pistes
dans cette tragédie la thaïlande n'a
jamais officiellement remis en question
ses façons de faire
toutes les pistes avancées tenait les
filles responsable de leur mort
les parents n'ayant jamais cru genre
d'homme repos je changerai pas d'idée si
des pesticides
karl bélanger a toujours été convaincus
qu'un pesticide était en cause mais
lequel
nous nous étions lancés sur cette piste
l'an dernier un mois après le décès des
filles
à notre arrivée sur l'île de pipi au
twin power the dance la chambre 103 ou
sont mortes noémie et audrey était en
restauration
nous avions loué une chambre à l'étagé
au dessus c'est les filles ont été
intoxiqués par un pesticide nous en
retrouverons peut-être des traces
[Musique]
de retour au québec qui nous avons fait
analyser nos échantillons à l'institut
national de santé publique
résultat il y avait dans la chambre
d'hôtel que nous avons alloué huit
produits chimiques pesticides
insecticides herbicides et fongicides au
niveau de leur toxicité non c'est très
très très peu probable que ces
substances l'on ait pu causer la mort
des défis moi je ne peux vraiment pas
dire de quoi
de quoi ils sont morts alors mais c'est
surprenant qu'ils aient deux décès qui
surviennent de façon très très rapide on
serait porté à croire qu'elle s'est
plutôt une intoxication que microbes
mais jamais temps ne pas trouver la
source de cette en norvège on n'arrivait
pas non plus à trouver la source de
l'intoxication de julie bonne rhymes ina
thompson s'est battu pendant quatre ans
pour obtenir des réponses et l'a
finalement réussi à convaincre le
département de médecine légale de son
pays à reprendre lé enquête d'octobre
le médecin était vraiment intéressé à ça
mais alors qu elle m'a beaucoup aidé
elle a cherché des experts partout dans
le monde
l'institut de norvège contact des
experts à travers le monde dont le
laboratoire de sciences judiciaires et
de médecine légale de montréal chargé de
faire une deuxième autopsie de noémie et
audrey bélanger
selon les analyses du laboratoire de
montréal le phosphure d'aluminium
pourrait être en cause dans un rapport
l'institut de santé publique de norvège
conclu que les quatre jeunes filles
mortes sur l'île de pipi julie boy
rhymes jesse saintonge noémie et audrey
bélanger avait tout les mêmes symptômes
ils ont fort probablement été intoxiqué
par un pesticide et ce pesticide serait
le phosphure d'aluminium laminé zène
mbc1 soit sec
ils ont éliminé toutes les autres
options expression des experts de
partout dans le monde qui sont arrivés à
cette conclusion qu'un club comme claude
et huguette mais qu'est ce que le
phosphure d'aluminium
comment ce pesticide at il pu tuer les
filles nous avons posé nos questions à
un expert en fumigation ce produit qui
est présent ici c'était le vrai pour s
nous tuer tous les deux dans les arts
dans les heures qui suivent
les vrais comprimés de fo sur
d'aluminium sont identiques à ceux ci
mais beaucoup trop toxique pourraient
être mis sur une table à l'air libre
chimiste de formation denis bureau
détient un permis du gouvernement pour
utiliser ce pesticide
le produit est utilisé principalement en
agriculture pour les ménages ont des
insectes relié à l'entreposage céréales
le faut sur d'aluminium est un pesticide
très toxique
au contact de l'air ou de l'humidité et
dégage un gaz mortel la phosphine un gaz
qui tue tout ce qui respire
si on utilise ce produit dans les hôtels
l'utilisation de ce mot d'avoir entraîné
la mort presque assuré de tout ce qui
vit que ce soit un humain ou un échec ou
un rat le gaz voix est éliminé et tuer
tout ce qui est présent dans la pièce au
bout d'environ une personne humaine va
mourir dans les deux heures les insectes
dans les 24 à 48 heures plus la
l'organiser gros et plus facile sera tué
les accès sont plus il a tué parce
qu'ils sont petits respire très peu ce
gaz est comparable au cyanure
il empêche les cellules de respirer et
bloque l'oxygénation des organes
l'intoxication produit un arrêt
respiratoire et surtout un arrêt des
organes respiratoires leplée poumons le
foie les reins et et où également il
travaille au niveau d'heure c'est une
limite globine celui ci il va au
parlement entraîné un changement de
couleur de la surface de la peau
changement de couleur de la poutre c'est
exactement ce que l'urgentologue qui
avait noué me audrey quelques heures
après leur mort nous avait décrit pour m
c'est ce que vaille elle nous a décrit
aussi sa peau avait changé de couleur
les tbh le web
ses lèvres était devenu bleu le bout de
ses doigts étaient bleus et ses ongles
de mains et de pieds sont devenus bleus
elle se sentait étourdie des sonos
selon denis bureau ce gaz peut
facilement se propager d'une chambre à
l'autre en passant sous la porte par
exemple ce qui expliquerait la mort de
gil et du lit dans deux chambres
voisines au canada comme dans plusieurs
autres pays
l'utilisation de ce pesticide est
strictement interdite
à 500 mètres d'un lieu d'habitation ce
produit nord est à usage restreint donc
très difficile à se procurer dans les
pays où la réglementation est sévère en
amérique du nord au canada en amérique
du sud
seuls les experts en fumigation est
accrédité et au mollet on pourrait dire
connu par les gouvernements hongrois
lusage dans une chambre fermée non
ventilées ce pesticide est hautement
toxiques pendant quelques heures mais
son effet pourrait durer plus longtemps
selon la littérature les étiquettes
maintenant nous suggère de ne pas
utiliser les gages pour traiter les
mettre là due à l'accumulation de gaz
entre les épaisseurs de mousse étant
donné que les mousses absorbé
normalement d'air et d'humidité de gaz
il est très très difficile et très long
sur toulon de d'éliminer complètement
tous les résidus de garde à l'intérieur
pourrait s'accumuler et être frappé à
l'intérieur de ses matelots
selon un rapport du gouvernement
thaïlandais ce pays a commencé à
utiliser le phosphure d'aluminium en
agriculture notamment pour les cultures
de riz en 2009
et coïncidence c'est aussi en 2009 que
surviennent les premiers décès ceux de
dire saintonge et judy bonne reim
a chiang maï en 2011 six touristes sont
morts dans des circonstances nébuleuses
4 dans le même hôtel
une coïncidence selon les autorités
thaïlandaises et d'aubry
mais si ce n'est qu'une coïncidence
pourquoi at on démolit cet hôtel at on
voulu effacer des traces de ce pesticide
qui aurait tué plusieurs touristes
[Musique]
le ce et est aujourd'hui à l'abandon le
propriétaire n'a pas voulu nous accorder
d'entrevue mais il nous dit qu'il a fait
démolir son hôtel pour des raisons
économiques
cook est une station balnéaire où
déferlent des centaines de milliers de
touristes chaque année
c'est aussi ici que l'on retrouve une
grande concentration de compagnie et
extermination avec une caméra cachée
nous sommes allés vérifier avec l'aide
d'une interprète si le phosphure
d'aluminium est utilisé dans les
chambres d'hôtel à la première
entreprise
on nous dit qu ils ne l'utilisent pas
elles ont miné
soit il
les bienvenus en adoptant à notre grande
surprise elle nous parle de décès
mystérieux de touristes en thaïlande qui
l'interdît games et la firme qu'elle
aurait été intoxiqué par un pesticide
souhaite donner à l'heure elle appelle
son patron pour en connaître le nom de
cesser ces tirs
nous donnons rendez-vous aux
propriétaires dans un centre commercial
un homme
i'm not your slaves des votants
m
le pylône
36 blessés
il nous explique que les gens d'affaires
dans le milieu de l'extermination
soupçonne que les décès de touristes
sont liées à un pesticide et que ça
pourrait bien être le phosphure d'indium
nous poursuivons notre tournée
mais de boost est souvent nous autres
pilotes du top 20
deux certitudes sans compter mais y
aussi pâti de cet impôt
qui sait
tout le monde semble avoir entendu
parler du décès des deux canadiennes
[Musique]
mais comme elle est
au niveau de tous les citer one
compagnie qu'elle sort s de débit forêts
redd a été demandé mais où cet
entrepreneur nous dit que plusieurs
soupçonnent les pesticides mais que le
sujet est tabou
il est au samedi
michel onfray des factures
nous nous sommes rendus dans sept
commerces sis nous ont dit ne pas
utiliser le poids sur d'aluminium mais
nous en avons trouvé un qui l'utilisent
dans les hôtels nous lui montrons des
répliques des comprimés de phosphure
d'aluminium que nous nous faisons passer
pour de futurs hôtelier qui cherchent de
l'information sur le faux sur
d'aluminium et son efficacité à long
terme de bad bank est magnifique
le canton de berne au port de gaza
ce n'est pas ce que notre spécialiste
nous a dit selon lui la phosphine peut
s'imprégner dans le matelas
ce grand jeu peut être présent et acculé
s'accumuler dans les matelas
c'est pour ça qu'on n'utilise pas pour
la pour le traitement de punaises dans
l'est dans les hôtels les fuites
potentielles sont très grand et très
risqué pour les gens qui pourrait
habiter dans l'est dans les champs
avoisinants
[Musique]
you can use
est-ce qu'on peut l'utiliser dans des
hôtels ou des maisons
[Musique]
certains hôteliers le ferais eux mêmes
ce pesticide est très facile à utiliser
elle nous en fait la démonstration
[Musique]
combien de mbudi qu'il en coûterait dix
mille bat 300 dollars canadiens pour une
pièce de la grandeur de son local ce
n'est qu'à la fin de notre rencontre
qu'elle reconnaît que le phosphure
d'aluminium peut être dangereux
[Musique]
avis à celles des séries adresse il y
aura du sang et or s'il est là qui va
ensuite eu aucun risque doit être
présent dans corée du sud a détecté mais
les effets sont là et permanent à
l'autopsié on voit pouvoir peut-être
reconnaître les symptômes mer les
résidus comme tels ne seront presque
jamais détectable
nous sommes allés rencontrer un des
médecins responsables de l' enquête sur
les décès de chiang maï
il ne peut pas confirmer qu'il s'agit de
phosphure d'aluminium mais le nom de
camille était ok il se jette mais alors
oui et non
donc l'eau y est dit john barbirolli 6 4
6 3 vous n'êtes pas seul
des tests ont tempéré
guère de doute en liga n'aura non non
non nous avons joint de nouveau la
propriétaire pour lui dire que son
utilisation du faux sur d'aluminium
était illégale et l'a maintenu qu'il
était possible d'obtenir un permis dans
certaines circonstances
[Musique]
le faux sur d'aluminium n'affecte pas
seulement des touristes ils tuent
ailleurs dans le monde en 2010 en août à
aux états unis le faux sur d'aluminium a
été utilisé pour éradiquer des rongeurs
dans cette maison n'est comprimé avait
été enfouie dans une tranchée à quelques
pieds de la résidence
les six membres de la famille ont été
malades maux d'estomac vomissements
difficultés à respirer
les deux plus jeunes âgés de 4 ans et
quinze mois sont morts
un drame qui a sonné l'alarmé sur la
dangerosité de ce pesticide depuis le
phosphure d'aluminium est un produit
chimique contrôlé au utah comme il est
ailleurs dans le monde mais on peut se
le procurer facilement sur internet
il y aurait aussi dans certains pays un
marché noir
dans les émirats arabes des compagnies
d'extermination utilisent illégalement
le phosphure d'aluminium qui ont des
immeubles à logements en juin dernier
sarah et brahim 11 ans est morte et
toxiques et la phosphine les policiers
ont trouvé des comprimés dans
l'appartement du voisin dans les émirats
arabes depuis 2008 neuf personnes
surtout des enfants ont été intoxiqués
de la même façon
plus récemment en janvier dernier la
fois cela fait deux autres victimes à
jérusalem les six membres de la famille
ont été gravement malade
mais les deux plus jeunes en sont morts
quant aux touristes ça n'arrive pas
qu'en thaïlande
une américaine carrie bowerman est morte
au vietnam en 2012 de façon mystérieuse
dans une chambre d'hôtel
plus récemment en janvier dernier deux
touristes de l'australie une mère et sa
fille de 14 ans sont mortes dans un
hôtel de bali en indonésie
elles sont tombées malades au milieu de
la nuit est transporté d'urgence à
l'hôpital
noël elle est morte avant d'y arriver
ivana va mourir quelques heures plus
tard pour l' agence de renseignement
américains le fbi il est possible qu'il
s'agisse d'un nouveau cas d'intoxication
à la phosphine ce qui ramènerait le
bilan à 13 morts dans trois pays
les enquêtes d'interpol et du fbi ait
s'étendent maintenant à toute l'asie et
vise un pesticide le phosphure
d'aluminium
[Musique]
dix-huit mois après le décès de noémie
et audrey bélanger la thaïlande à
étudier toutes les pistes empoisonnement
alimentaire drogue champignons
[Musique]
toutes ces pistes ont été écartés une
après l'autre
le gouvernement reconnaît maintenant que
les pesticides sont probablement en
cause une pièce janvier l'explication la
plus plausible c'est que c'est une
intoxication sévère une intoxication un
produit chimique qui appartient à la
famille des pesticides chimiques rôle
d'abby l'on sait la meilleure
explication que nous avons pu trouver
est-ce que ce pourrait être due fois sur
d'aluminium nous ne pouvons pas
l'exclure
il est sur la liste sur la liste des
produits que nous surveillons
[Musique]
dans notre cas ça fait un soulagement
que vous l'ayez conclu que dire que
c'est des pesticides c'est un
soulagement
on peut pas dire à 100% qu'on était sûr
mais à 95%
on le savait que c'était pas un avantage
on le savait que cet apport n'en saurez
pas douter de zone
sur les caméras de surveillance parce
que la police est venue chez nous que
nous ont montré les caméras de
surveillance de l'hôtel et puis on les
voit entrer dans le champ qui sont ils
pas en état d'ébriété sont pour ils
rentrent pas en titubant
nos feuilleter voire à très bien droite
dans le genre suite à ça près qu'une
fois qu'ils ont été rentrés à
l'intérieur de le chant bien sûr plus
fait que tu dis il faut que cela se soit
produit dans la chambre des communes au
delà
alors que la thaïlande reconnaît qu'un
pesticide peut être en cause
et l'offre à karl et linda bélanger
10000 dollars en compensation pour
chacune de leur fille ils ont refusé
ils veulent que justice soit faite c'est
l'hôtel avait été fermé
si l'autorité cette autorité qui aurait
fait très mal et les dérange dans
l'argent une racaille au lieu de comme
vous dites quand vous êtes allé et çà de
là que la chambre était de vider qui
avait tout enlever tout nu est-ce qu'ils
vont aller plus loin est-ce qu'ils vont
sanctionner l'hôtel est ce qu'ils vont
est illégal ici si tu t'en sers tu vas
payer pour la bord ils vont te protéger
et non pas d'abord pop au garden hotel
est encore ouverte puis il ya même les
autorités le zoo aider à nettoyer des
lieux
[Musique]
moi je pense qu'ils ont souffert mais
elles sont pas eu connaissance c'est
peut-être parce que je me protège d'un
projet peut-être là mais moi je pense
que la façon qu'ils ont été trouvés
cacher
je te croyais un peu pour pratiquer à
mes choix âmes et y briller
je suis pas d'accord pour par leurs
gardiens j'ai complètement terrassé
chaque matin quand je me réveille et
deux photos sont là je les regarde je
lui dis et des mois pour cette journée
là
[Musique]
mais bale michael caine de picchio de
punaises j'aurais pas mal préféré que
mon fils revienne piqué de la tête aux
pieds
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]